is done one interview and the
interviewer asked him all these
questions he was like no he says in the
interview that he's had a compulsion
since he was a kid to he's thought of a
way to kill every person that he's ever
met his entire life Jesus Christ you're
on that list this no this gets this gets
even crazier because he said in that
same interview that the morning that he
woke up he was gonna kill everybody in
the house but he slept in and we had all
got up and gone to work no way dude I
swear this guy openly admits to saying I
was gonna kill everybody I was living
with but I slept in and they were gone
so I went to my parents house and killed
them instead yeah holy
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today
foreign